so it looks like us Marvel fans might be
getting the Best of Both Worlds when it
comes to the next Avengers film or
perhaps the next two a lot of talk of
the future of the MCU specifically in
regards to Kang the Conqueror being the
future of the MCU has been happening a
lot recently of course this is because
of everything that has happened with
Jonathan Majors now for a while now
we've been hearing that Marvel Studios
might be considering moving away from K
the Conqueror and Jonathan Majors as the
main villain of the Multiverse Saga
which when we first heard sounded really
absurd something like they just couldn't
do how could you move away from your big
bad that you clearly set up with Loki
season 1 Ant-Man on the WASP Quantum
Mania big time there and then Loki
season 2 but that's when we found out
that K the Conqueror originally wasn't
supposed to be the big bat of the
Multiverse Saga he wasn't actually the
big bat in their initial plans for the
Saga however after they saw Jonathan
Major's performance as Kang they decided
Kang would be the big bad so then the
big question was well if they're going
to move away from Kang who is going to
be the new big bad and then we got a
report from variety stating that Marvel
was considering replacing Kang with Dr
Doom now this hit people in a lot of
different ways some people thought that
this was awesome Dr Doom is amazing some
people thought well Kang was already set
up why are they replacing him just
recast Jonathan major as Kang a lot of
mix feelings especially when Jonathan
major has really done an incredible job
portraying Kang and his variance and if
he's innocent a lot of people would
really love to see him remain King the
Conqueror I one of those people and
luckily for us it looks like that is
going to be the case and before people
start saying dang it that sucks I wanted
Dr Doom in the MCU it looks like that
could also still be the case we could be
looking at a Multiverse Saga where Kang
remains and Dr Doom makes his MCU debut
it looks like we could be getting the
Best of Both Worlds insiders say that
Kang is staying in the MCU whether or
not Jonathan major is found guilty or
innocent in his trial they will simply
recast if he is found guilty we'll break
down everything you need to know in this
video and of course if you're new be
sure to subscribe to the channel so you
can stay up to date on all things
relating to the MCU and if you subscribe
and leave a comment you're automatically
entered in our giveaway for a chance to
win a PS5 and Xbox series X some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items the
winner gets to pick one item and we pick
one winner at the end of each month so
luckily for us a few insiders have
stated that despite the Variety article
and despite reports from Joanna Robinson
who wrote MCU the reign of Marvel
Studios Marvel Studios is going to keep
Kang in the MCU it may be true that they
were considering moving in a different
direction I don't doubt that at all I
believe they probably were considering
that and were seriously considering
placing Kang with doom we know that
Marvel Studios recently went on their
big Retreat and during this Retreat we
have been told that it was a very
different feeling than the previous ones
their previous Retreats were pretty
positive and everybody was pretty
confident however this time everybody
knew that they had some stuff to talk
about because they had a lot of changes
they need to make and talk about and we
were told the future of Jonathan major
and King the Conqueror was a big subject
and of course it was that's a big
problem for Marvel Studios but according
to a recent report from Daniel rpk he
stated I heard from my sources that
Marvel is still committed to Kang it's
possible that they'll do a recast but
they're not leaving the character aside
if Doom appears in secret Wars he won't
be the main villain now I personally
really like this I love what they have
set up so far in Loki season 1 quantam
Mania Loki season 2 and what they have
planned for the future I'm really
excited to see Kang and his variants be
the big bats but I am also really
excited at the possibility of Doom
entering the MCU at the same time I get
even more excited about the fact that we
could actually see Doom verse Kang and
as we've Ted talked about before this
could be done in an extremely cool way
from what we've heard so far the main
villain of Secret Wars as Daniel rpk
mentioned isn't going to be Doom but
from what we've heard it's supposed to
be king as a beyonder variant the
beyonder himself isn't going to show up
but will have a version of Kang who
essentially is the beyonder it's still
going to be Kang with the powers of the
beyonder just want to make that clear
now this is exactly what happens in the
Marvel comic story of secret Wars and in
one of the stories how we get God
Emperor Doom is that Doom takes the
powers of the beyonder and although I'm
not sure that will happen per se in the
MCU I think a similar story would happen
with Kang and Dr Doom but as I mentioned
the other day they would have to do this
in a pretty specific way the Doom that
they get would have to come from Another
Universe perhaps maybe it could be
Julian McMahan from the original
Fantastic Four film I think that would
be really really cool and we know they
are bringing some of those older Marvel
characters back from those older
franchises in Deadpool 3 and Secret Wars
so although I don't think Dr Doom is
ultimately going to be the big bad like
Daniel rpk States I do think him and
doom are going to Hash it out at some
point in time because it just makes
sense we have Dr Doom one of the
greatest characters and villains of all
time in Marvel history wanting to rule
everything and when he comes across King
the Conqueror I think he's going to take
that opportunity to take some of his
time travel technology his Multiverse
technology however I think the king Trio
beats him only because they have been
around for what seems to be centuries
and they really understand how time and
the Multiverse Works whereas Doom would
be coming in pretty much as a newbie
trying to figure it all out but I do
think in secret Wars he is going to play
a decent role now I do want to address
one rumor that has been going around
about Kang the Conqueror specifically
Jonathan Major's playing King the
Conqueror there appears to be some type
of rumor out there that states Marvel
Studios can't actually recast Kang the
Conqueror in the MCU because of some
contract that Marvel signed with
Jonathan major this contract is
apparently why Marvel Studios was
considering replacing King with doom
because apparently they could not recast
him this is what the report said coming
from weekly planets hot scoop where
listeners send in rumors to them and one
email they got said this while working
on the movie devotion I was friends with
one of Jonathan major people during our
filming Jonathan major closed the deal
for Kang I remember asking the friend
about it and they shared some details
more interestingly due to the nature of
the character and potential multiple
versions Jonathan major had a contract
claw stating that only he could play any
and all versions of Kang this would
likely explain the rumors of swapping
out Kang with doom as opposed to
recasting this most likely is not true
it's very unlikely that Marvel Studios
put this kind of clause in there however
it's kind of a moot point and let me
explain if Jonathan major is found
innocent Mar Marvel Studios is simply
going to continue on with what they had
planned Jonathan Majors will still be
Kang the Conqueror the story will still
feature Kang and his variant as the main
villains of the Multiverse Saga all will
be well however if he's found guilty
that would probably void his contract
most of these contracts have morality
Clauses in them and there are definite
legal things in place in contracts that
protect the studio from any wrongdoing
or harm that the actors may cause so if
Jonathan major is found innocent all is
well he REM King but if he's found
guilty that would most likely void the
contract so it wouldn't really matter
Marvel Studios could recast Jonathan
Majors as king the Conqueror if they
want it or they could simply bring in
Doom but based off of what we've heard
all of these different reports from all
of these different insiders it sounds
like they are planning to keep King the
Conqueror but also bring in Victor Von
Doom which honestly is something I would
really love to see however again I don't
think it should be the main Doom that is
going to be coming in the future but I
think it should be a variant of Doom
that would try to take on Kang the
Conqueror but let me know your thoughts
about this in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest news you can find us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof